california unveils a plan to become an
abortion sanctuary if roe vs wade is
overturned and david brooks rips the
state of modern conservatism i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first your reminder that if
you're trying to help your budget this
holiday season you have to check out
puretalk if you want to be a hero for
the holidays how about getting your
loved one a brand new iphone that's
right pure talk has iphone 12 starting
at just 479 through the end of the year
they have the 13s as well i switched
over to pure talk i'm getting great
nationwide 5g coverage that is the same
coverage as the big guys because they
use the same cell phone towers as one of
the big guys you can do the same
the average family saves over 800 a year
which is just smart like why are you not
doing that i would not tell you to use a
service that i'm not completely happy
with make the switch with puretalk's
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose unlimited talk text six
gigs of data just 30 bucks a month and
as i say the iphone 12 just 479 go to
puretalk.com shop for the plan and phone
that's right for you then enter promo
code shapiro save an additional 50 off
your very first month and save on a new
phone that's puretalk.com promo code
shapiro puretalk is simply smarter
wireless some restrictions apply see
site for details go check them out once
more at puretalk.com use promo code
superior to save an additional 50 off
your very first month save on a new
phone and save hundreds of bucks down
the road alrighty so
i escaped california in 2020 and frankly
i feel like i was a couple of years too
late i'd been discussing with my wife
the possibility of leaving california
for a while i've been discussing with my
business partner jeremy boring the
possibility of taking our company and
moving it out of state for quite a while
but finally we pulled the trigger in
2020 and not a moment too soon as it
turns out because california has now
reduced itself to a smoldering ash heap
apparently it is amazing how governance
makes a difference it really does
because california has been blessed with
some of the greatest assets that god has
ever bestowed upon mankind it's got
beautiful natural scenery it's got
unbelievable natural resources it has
high levels of intellectual capital it's
a huge bustling population and yet
somehow they are turning california into
a dystopian hellscape it truly is an
unbelievable thing
and the vision for california has
changed and if california is sort of the
harbinger of the future from the left
then it behooves us to take a look at
what california has become
the california dream
used to be that you would come out to
california you get a job maybe working
at jpl or maybe working in hollywood and
then you'd be able to afford a house in
burbank or a house in the san fernando
valley amidst the orange groves
with a white picket fence and two and a
half kids and you'd be able to create a
life for yourself this was the promise
of california and if you look back at
the old tourism videos from the 1950s in
california this was the pitch everything
was clean and new
okay now obviously this is not to
pretend that there were no problems in
california or in the country in 1953 the
most obvious being segregation although
in california segregation was lower than
it was in most other places in the
country l.a was one of the least
segregated cities in america in the
1950s but
to pretend that racism wasn't a massive
problem in the 1950s is of course silly
but that's not the point the point is
that the vision that was being presented
for what life would be like in a
thriving california was pretty simple it
was law abiding you had shows on tv
in the 50s and 60s about the greatness
of the lapd you had a generalized
feeling of opportunity this is a great
place to raise a family
here's a tourism video from 1953 sort of
bragging about what's best in california
in the years since the turn of the
century los angeles has grown from a
sleepy pueblo to a vast seeding
metropolitan city
fine buildings huge stores busy citizens
this is hollywood boulevard and the
world renowned grumman's chinese theater
in the forecourt of this celebrated
cinema house are the footprints of the
outstanding stars of the screen it is
almost unnecessary to say that among the
chief attractions of the southern
california picture is its many miles of
beaches where you can be as athletic as
you choose or just lull around and build
up a beautiful tan
okay so um if you went back to
california right now and you went to
each one of those sites they're
hellholes they really are i mean that
video opens driving through downtown los
angeles right you see city hall in that
in that particular video and city hall
is now slum row
it it is a it is a homeless encampment
and then they show groutman's chinese
right on on hollywood boulevard
and they're close to sunset and vine
over there and that's kind of the center
of hollywood that place has been taken
over by the homeless a couple of years
ago there was a person who literally had
a bucket of feces thrown on her at the
intersection that they show in that
video and then they show santa monica
beach which used to be clean and nice
santa monica beach is so bad that the
weekend before my family left california
and we were getting kind of nostalgic
because my wife and i had gone on our
first date
at the coffee bean near santa monica
beach and then we had gone for a walk
along the beach and even then it wasn't
so bad this is 2008
2007 late 2007
and um and we went back there as sort of
a sort of nostalgia play we brought our
kids to a park on santa monica beach
where a homeless man was trying to
expose himself to people another
homeless man was spitting at patrons of
a restaurant and open needles were
visible everywhere
they have wrecked california they've
completely wrecked it and they seem to
be
morally invested in wrecking california
they seem to feel good about wrecking
california
it's as though they've decided that all
of the benefits of living in california
have to go away and the way that they're
going to make up for the for the
complete failure of their system of
thought is by proclaiming their own
moral superiority so the latest
the latest round of this sort of
insanity comes courtesy of the
associated press
it's an amazing amazing story it really
says all that you need to know about
what california is and where california
is going
apparently california is seeking to
become now what they call an abortion
sanctuary
i'll get to this in just one moment
because i mean that's just evil i'm
sorry so you have decided that your
state's tourism industry is now going to
be based on women coming to kill their
babies within your borders
so my new state of florida we're paying
police officers like 10 grand bonuses to
come and help protect the population
california they're literally now saying
that they will pay the the hotel bills
for women who wish to decamp to
california to kill their unborn children
it's a pretty stark contrast we'll get
to this story in just one moment because
it really does demon if this is the
future of the country we are so screwed
we are screwed beyond all comprehension
first let's talk about your sleep
quality so if all of this messes with
your sleep quality as it would with mine
you need a mattress that is going to do
you well so
i'm at a hotel right now i'm not on my
mattress at home and i'll be honest with
you i slept like crap i need my mattress
at home i need my helix sleep mattresses
made just for me
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep everybody is unique helix knows
that they have several different
mattress models to choose from they've
got soft medium and firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot mattress is great for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains even a helix plus size
mattress for plus size sleepers so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress you
match to the mattress comes right to
your doorship for free you don't ever
need to go to a mattress store again
you've got a 10-year warranty you get to
try it out for 100 nights risk free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will helix even
has financing options and flexible
payment plans so a great night's sleep
is never far away and i love my helix
sleep mattress you will too go to
helixsleep.com take their two minutes
sleep quiz they'll match you to that
customized mattress that'll give you the
best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com
ben alright so according to the
associated press
california is seeking to become what
they now call an abortion sanctuary so
first of all i just want to point out
the the linguistic insanity of that
phrase the word sanctuary comes from the
same root as the word sanctified
right a sanctuary is a place that is
sanctified that is what a sanctuary is
and
in the in the before times and when when
there were ecclesiastical courts
throughout europe
you were able to rush to a church if you
wish to avoid criminal culpability
people would rush to churches
for sanctuary right they would claim
sanctuary this is obviously a major plot
point in for example the administrator
cube goes hunchback of notre dame
is people rushing into is esmeralda
rushing into the cathedral of notre dame
and claiming sanctuary right saying that
she wishes to be subject to
ecclesiastical law as opposed to the the
king's law
sanctuary was a way of claiming god's
providence over you and not the state's
providence
now you have the state of california
declaring sanctuary
for either illegal activity in the form
of illegal immigration or for
the worst sin in american life abortion
it's now going to be a sanctuary a
sanctified place protected from all
others
for abortion
you're not rushing to avoid culpability
for a for an act for which you believe
you are innocent
you instead are rushing to a sanctified
place where your abortion can be
protected
the the language is is so paganistic as
to shock the conscience according to the
associated press with more than two
dozen states poised to ban abortion if
the united states supreme court gives
them okay next year california clinics
and their allies in the state
legislature on wednesday revealed a plan
to make the state a sanctuary for those
seeking reproductive care to euphemism
including possibly paying for travel
lodging and procedures for people from
other states
so they're not just saying we're going
to keep abortion legal in california
which is exactly what you would expect
of course they're literally saying that
they will take the taxpayer dollars of
the people who pay taxes in california
to pay women to come to the states to
kill their unborn children so remember
the california dream was come here raise
a family buy a house get a job
lead a law-abiding life and contribute
to the building of the world's greatest
economy
and now the california dream is move to
california get a crappy one-bedroom
studio apartment have a homeless guy
sitting directly outside your door
shooting heroin into his feet
and if you need an abortion we'll pay
your hotel and maybe medical bills the
california dream is come on over here
we'll put you up at the hilton and we'll
carve that baby right out of you
that is a rather astonishing change and
bespeaks a suicidal society any society
that is actively incentivizing abortion
is is a suicidal society there's no
other way to put it you're literally
destroying your fertility rates you're
destroying your future on a literal
level the k if kids are the future as
the left constantly agrees right we all
agree kids are the future because there
literally is no future without kids then
actively fomenting the killing of unborn
children
seems to be anti-future but california
isn't about building a future anymore
california is about a vision of utopian
society in which full stasis has been
reached
if you've found a company in california
right now you're an idiot
i've talked to some of the biggest
industrial founders in california i've
talked to some of the biggest tech
people in california people like with
i promise you the biggest tech companies
in california and they've told me
personally if they were founding their
companies today there is no way in hell
they would put those companies in
california there's a reason that elon
musk just moved tesla's headquarters out
of california
there's a reason for this this is a
dying state and they are choosing the
death this is a suicidal state in terms
of policy
and a morally benefited state at that
the california future of abortion
council made up of more than 40 abortion
providers and advocacy groups according
to the ap released a list of 45
recommendations for the state to
consider if the high court overturns roe
versus wade the 48 year old decision
that forbids states from outlawing
abortion
the recommendations are not just a
liberal fantasy some of the state's most
important policy makers helped write
them including tony atkins the san diego
democrat who leads the state senate and
attended multiple meetings
democratic governor gavin newsom started
the group himself and in an interview
last week with the ap said some of the
report's details will be included in his
budget proposal in january we will be a
sanctuary newsom said adding he's aware
patients will likely travel to
california from other states to seek
abortions we're looking at ways to
support that inevitability and looking
at ways to expand our protections
california already pays for abortions
for many low-income residents through
the state's medicaid program and
california is one of six states that
require private insurance companies to
cover abortions although many patients
still up end up paying deductibles and
co-payments
but money won't be a problem for state
funded abortion services for patients
from other states california's coffers
have soared throughout the pandemic
fueling a record budget surplus this
year you know why the california coffers
sword because the federal government
pumped so much money into the economy
that california actually increased its
tax take
for all the jabbering about how states
were going to go bankrupt because of
kovid states made money during covet
because the because the federal
government
pumped an unprecedented amount of money
into the economy
and then california just taxed it they
have shed a state surplus last year
next year the state's independent
legislative office predicts california
will have a surplus of about 31 billion
of course none of that takes into
account the structural debts that the
state of california has which probably
run into the hundreds of billions or
trillions at this point
california's abortion providers are
asking the state to make it easier for
people to get to the state the report
recommends funding including public
spending to support patients seeking
abortion for travel expenses like gas
lodging transportation and child care so
some states try to incentivize you to
come to their state by giving you a job
or giving you a child tax credit or
something the state of california is
encouraging people to come to the state
of abortion to the state of abortion
come to the state of california
and be paid to perform abortions uh
full-scale moral insanity
they're asking lawmakers to reimburse
abortion providers for services to those
who can't afford to pay
a huge influx of people from other
states will definitely destabilize the
abortion provider network said fabiola
carrion the interim director for
reproductive and sexual health at the
national health law program she said
out-of-state abortions would also likely
be later term procedures which are more
complicated and more expensive the
report asks lawmakers to help clinics
increase their workforce to prepare for
more patients by giving scholarships to
medical students who pledge to offer
abortion services in rural areas help
them pay off their student loans and
assist with their monthly liability
insurance premiums
so now we are going to
pay up-and-coming medical students to
violate hippocratic oath
amazing amazing stuff and again speaks
to the morality of california where it
is all about a feeling of of consonance
with left-wing morality and not at all
about the quality of life or future of
the state which is why if you are in
california and you do not agree with
this stuff get the hell out now run i've
been telling people this since we left
okay i stuck around for as long as i
thought it was possible to stay around i
do not understand why people are
sticking around in california if they
have a shred of sanity about them at
this point this is not getting better it
is getting worse
there is no point in california where
they are going to turn around and
realize that they've completely botched
this thing beyond all recognition
they're not going to do it there are too
many democrats in the state
california is the most populous
republican state they're the most
republicans in california of any state
because the population of california is
upwards of 40 million
if you are a red state person in the
blue state of california get out while
the getting is good
move to a purple state move to a red
state it'll improve your life radically
and you won't be complicit in the
taxpayer funding of the of the death of
the unborn the fact that this has become
the california dream it's a california
nightmare
unreal and by the way the california
nightmare is on every scale it's on
every scale it makes elites feel really
good about themselves because they they
can say i paid for this poor this poor
woman's abortion i paid for her abortion
that homeless guy he gets to live on the
street because of me
and we even have needle exchanges look
how much sympathy we have for people
we're not prosecuting criminals we want
those criminals to be out on the street
should somebody's life be ruined just
because they engage in a smash and grab
every so often
i'm glad that they feel good about
themselves because they can afford to to
wall themselves off in their own little
but that ain't the real world and
california is becoming a hellscape for
the vast majority of its citizens at
this point
and we'll get some more on california in
just one second because as goes
california so goes the entire left if
you think this is going to stop at
california you're wrong it starts in
california and then it moves throughout
all of the blue states
first let's talk about the fact that
you're going to spend probably a little
bit too much this holiday season because
everybody spends too much this holiday
season but you should be giving yourself
the gift of extra money in your pocket
you can pay off your credit card
balances and save with a credit card
consolidation loan from lightstream roll
your high interest credit card payments
into just one payment at a lower fixed
rate lightstream's credit card
consolidation loans have rates as low as
4.98 apr with auto pay and excellent
credit
get a loan from 5 000 to a hundred
thousand dollars there are no fees you
can even get your money as soon as the
day you apply lightstream believes that
people with good credit deserve a better
loan experience that's exactly what they
deliver just for my listeners apply
right now get a special interest rate
discount and save even more the only way
to get that discount is to go to
lightstream.com
shapiro again that's
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com
shapiro subject to credit approval rates
range from four point nine eight percent
apart to 19.99 apr includes 0.50
auto pay discount lowest rate requires
excellent credit terms and conditions
supply officers are subject to change
without notice visit lightstream.com
shapiro for more information
already so obviously it's not just
abortion that is a california issue it
is just the most obvious moral
abomination in which california wishes
to be complicit they're literally acting
as a magnet for the killing of the
unborn that's an unreal thing it is one
thing to say that california wishes to
retain legal abortion you would expect
nothing less it's california but for
california to say that they actively
want to pay people to come to california
to have abortions is
it's not it's just nuts
okay meanwhile criminality in california
continues to be a massive issue smash
and grabs organized smashing grabs are a
thing there's an 81 year old woman who's
recently shot inside her own home and
robbed
there's a man who's recently shot on the
street in california for his watch
he's in his car somebody walked up shot
him took his watch
and uh the reason for this
is pretty obvious it's because
california has decided that criminality
will no longer count as crime they've
defined crime down there's a famous
phrase from former senator daniel
patrick moynihan it was defining
deviancy down his suggestion is that as
a society when you say something is no
longer deviant it becomes more common
which makes sense when you subsidize
things they become more common and when
you find crime down crime becomes more
common so if you take a felony and you
treat it as a misdemeanor you will get
more of that behavior if you take a
misdemeanor and you treat it as a
non-crime you'll get more of that
behavior
this is exactly what you're hearing from
the beverly hills police chief who said
yesterday that the big problem here is
that we are catching the same criminals
over and over and over again and then
just releasing them back onto the
streets
i have great technical systems here to
catch criminals and that's the thing
we're catching the criminals and the
problem is we're catching them over and
over again and they're being released
very quickly without bail and they're
not staying in prison so we just
continue to deal with the same same
people again and again that's mark
stainbrook he is the beverly hills
police chief he said this is a
confluence of about 10 years of laws and
policy making starting with prop 47 then
ab109 then prop 57 which essentially
decriminalized many of the crimes in
california and it makes people in
california feel good about themselves
that they are doing this i mean sure
it's completely destroying quality of
life sure it's making street crime a
thing again in california but it makes
the liberal elites feel so good about
themselves
meanwhile a safeway store in san
francisco according to daily wire is now
investing heavily into security systems
to prevent smash and grab robberies the
move comes as major metro areas
especially san francisco and other
california cities combat a wave of group
thefts in which large crowds of armed
people rob stores and overwhelm
employees
according to kpix 5 san francisco
customers say they've noticed more
security guards inside and outside the
store now they're seeing more security
gates and barriers at the entrance an
automatic gate closes after each person
to make it harder for thieves to make a
run for it safeway added polls to its
shopping carts to make them difficult to
remove from the store it closed off a
side exit it added a wall of water
bottles directing customers to the front
exit
according to a statement from safeway
like other local businesses we are
working on ways to curtail escalating
theft to ensure the well-being of our
customers and to foster a welcoming
environment for our customers their
safety remains top priority these long
planned security improvements were
implemented with these goals in mind
none of this should be a shock i mean
this is what california has fostered
meanwhile the homeless crisis in
california continues to get worse and
worse and worse according to mike madrid
writing for the for the sacramento bee
quote
of all the disturbing societal trends
that have been normalized over the past
few years it's homelessness that stands
alone is the most morally outrageous and
shameful the visible daily reminder of
the collapse of one of the government's
most basic responsibilities is a blight
on california and the policy makers who
created the problem and simultaneously
demonstrate complete incompetence in
addressing it
one in four homeless people in america
lives on california streets remember
population california is about 40
million population of the united states
about 330 million one in four homeless
people in the entire country live in
california
most of california's homeless problem is
the result of policy failures in
sacramento which is why no other state
has anywhere near the problem california
does according to mike madrid
it says next year will mark 10 years
since the elimination of the most
powerful tools cities had to house
low-income residents redevelopment
allowed cities to designate areas in
their community for future development
opportunities and keep sales tax revenue
generated by future projects cities
could borrow against that revenue stream
and set aside
money for affordable housing but it's
not about the affordable housing it's
about the fact that california has
decided to incentivize homelessness by
saying that the police can't do anything
about it
california now says that you're not
allowed to move the crap that homeless
people leave on the streets because it
is their crap
california has suggested it's a
fundamental freedom for people to live
on the streets
and then you're surprised that homeless
people are are rushing in droves to
california
and how about basic taxpayer services
are we getting any of that in california
so they're not handling crime
they're not handling homelessness
they're not handling you know the basis
basic day-to-day functions of government
but they're going to pay people to come
do abortions in california by the way 34
000 lausc students are going to not be
able to attend school because of
simultaneous regulatory mandates put
down by the state of california
according to ktla yesterday about 34 000
students have not yet complied with the
covet 19 vaccine mandate in lausd
there's no longer enough time for
students who haven't gotten their first
shot to be fully vaccinated by january
10th which means that you could have
tens of thousands of lausd students who
are not even allowed to attend school
so california is not performing basic
functions they're just performing out
the left-wing fantasies of the
fantasists
and presumably this is the sort of
policy that democrats would like to see
adopted across the nation after all
gavin newsom is a national hero to
members of the left
and people by the way are
making that move with their feet they're
doing what we did if they're in
california new york illinois people are
leaving they've decided they want no
more of this and the left just continues
along with it
in just a second we're going to get to
the the critique of conservatism put
forth by david brooks who used to be the
quote unquote conservative at the new
york times because i think it speaks to
the the conflict the ideological
conflict that is happening in the
country and the complete ignorance of a
certain level of elite quote unquote
conservative to deal with the realities
on the ground of our current situation
first let's talk about the perfect gift
hey the perfect gift this holiday season
is steak there's no better gift than
steak and let me tell you about omaha
steaks omahasteaks.com is gonna get you
the steaks that you need omahasteaks.com
enter shapiro into the search bar you
can save over 50 when you order the
perfect gift package today for 99.99 you
get the world famous bacon wrapped filet
mignons chicken breasts sides desserts
and so much more when you use code
shapiro you not only save over 50 you
also get an additional eight omaha
steaks burgers free with your order
omaha steaks is ready to ship right now
order that perfect gift package today at
omahasteaks.com don't forget you'll get
eight free burgers when entering code
shapiro in the search bar and if you're
a new customer ordering for the first
time enter shapiro at checkout get 20
off select packages
achieving gifting greatness with omaha
steaks incredible flavor incredible
value 100 guaranteed you know a couple
of years back omaha steaks got me like a
kosher steak let me tell you that thing
lives on in my memory because it was so
spectacular you can make the magic
happen for friends and family this
holiday season omahasteaks.com keyword
shapiro for the perfect gift package
today okay so if california is governed
like garbage and if life is getting
worse in places like california and if
businesses are fleeing and if the state
has decided that its top priority is not
to enforce the law and protect its
taxpayers but to in fact tax the
taxpayers in order for people to get
abortions
then
how exactly
why why do democrats keep voting for
this why do people keep voting for this
and the answer is the feeling of
unearned moral superiority
that is the answer
because it certainly is not the policy
successes it's a feeling like life is
worse in the big cities right now life
is worse in new york city they're
telling you that you can't take your
five-year-old to mcdonald's without
faxing your kid
they're telling you in la usd you cannot
send your kids to school without faxing
your kid
hey life is getting worse in these
places so what what is the draw
why
and the answer is the unearned feeling
of moral superiority the belief that
you're just better than those other guys
there's a piece in salon.com
today which really sums this up from the
excrement amanda marcotte
she has a piece today titled young
democrats are right there is no reason
to date or befriend trump voters
so she's talking about a new poll from
axios the new poll from axios shows that
only five percent of republicans said
they wouldn't be friends with someone
from the opposite party but 37 of
democrats say they would not be friends
with a republican
also 71 of democrats would not go on a
date with someone with opposing views
versus 31
of republicans
now i'll be honest with you i think
there's a big difference between being
friends with somebody and dating
somebody because my vision of dating is
that you end up marrying somebody i
really think that you should share
values with somebody that you marry so
on a dating level i sort of agree with
the notion that you should have a
baseline agreement on values but i
understand that's not how people
actually date people now date for
pleasure or date for sex or date for a
variety of other reasons that don't
involve marriage at the end of the at
the end of that chain
but
the basic finding of the survey is
pretty clear which is that republicans
are pretty tolerant of democrats but
democrats are absolutely intolerant of
republicans according to amanda marcotte
this is a good thing because democrats
are superior human beings and this is
the argument you are seeing throughout
american politics this has been going on
for a long time i wrote a book in 2012
called bullies the basic premise of
which was that the left liked to claim
that the right was the bullying force in
american public life but the real
bullying force in american public life
are people of the left who truly believe
that they are morally superior to the
people with whom they share our country
and amanda marcotte makes that case
quite beautifully
she says
she says this is about desirability not
tolerance democrats are desirable as
friends and lovers not just to their
fellow party members but to republicans
as well you see democrats are so
wonderful that even republicans want to
hang out with democrats the republicans
are so garbage that democrats don't want
to hang out with them only only stupid
republicans would want to deal with
other republicans so she says democrats
are desirable as friends and lovers not
just their fellow party members but to
republicans as well but republicans they
apparently don't have much to offer to
democrats as friends and certainly not
as lovers digging into the polling shows
why this is
as the axios write up by neil rothschild
notes young democrats believe the gop
positions spearheaded by former
president trump are far outside of the
mainstream and polite conversation in
particular human rights and not just
policy differences are at stake
right these would be the human rights
like killing the unborn these would be
the human rights according to the left
like pretending that a boy is a girl and
indoctrinating kids to believe that they
can be members of the opposite gender
these would be human rights like saying
that it is a good thing for people to
live in their own filth
on sunset boulevard shooting heroin into
their feet these are the human rights
that democrats definitely need to
maintain and if you disagree with them
on policy this means that you oppose
human rights
amanda marcotte says no duh just last
week the gop controlled supreme court
made it clear they plan to strip basic
bodily autonomy rights from everyone
with uterus the republican party is
rallying around violent white
supremacist rhetoric
relatedly a harvard poll from last week
shows more than half of young americans
feel democracy in the country is under
threat over a third think they may see a
second u.s civil war within their
lifetimes this isn't about a dispute
over marginal tax rates if you quite
correctly believe that republicans are
plotting to destroy democracy why would
you want to be friends with people who
support that
and this is the case that amanda
marcotte is and this is the case that
california's democrats are making right
as their governance gets worse and worse
the specter of the opposing party has to
get worse and worse to justify that you
have to somehow make an excuse to
yourself for why you suck at your job
and your excuses well the other guy is
so much worse
it's so those people are so much worse
according to amanda marcotte the anger
on the right over this polling shows
this isn't really about liberal
intolerance but an ugly sense of
entitlement among conservatives it's
fueled by a belief that they should be
as obnoxious cruel and bigoted as they
want without having to pay any social
penalty for it that attitude is
especially troubling when it comes to
dating and is tied to long-standing
sexist assumption that women owe men
their time and attention even when they
don't find them attractive
oh is that is that what it is
really it really
so you're going to boil down republicans
pointing out that if you won't be
friends with somebody from the opposing
side of the aisle this means that it's
very difficult to share a polity you're
gonna boil that down to men feel a sense
of entitlement from women
she says
that the the bottom line here is that
republicans need to suck less
right you need to be just be a democrat
and then we will deal with you
but otherwise quote unquote good is what
she says
good on young democrats for seeing
clearly what the joe scarboroughs of the
world don't want them to see which is
that republicans are bad people and you
should never ever treat them as fully
human
hilariously she then claims that
republicans don't treat people as fully
human right the entire column is about
treating republicans is not fully human
and then her and then her complaint
about republicans is that they
dehumanize people okay but this lies
behind so much democratic rhetoric these
days it lies behind half of what joe
biden says and the entire democratic
agenda right now is to paint political
opposition as people who oppose
democracy
how deeply rooted is this idea it's so
deeply rooted that joe biden is about to
have a quote-unquote democracy summit
and at this democracy summit there's a
serious pitch for joe biden
to tell other democracies that american
democracy is on the verge of extinction
which is crazy okay that's insane if
we're talking about why american
democracy is on the verge of extinction
there are some pretty good systemic
reasons such as an authoritarian
administrative state that is not
answerable to the people
creating regulations from whole cloth
that apply to tens of millions of
americans like say maybe an osha of ax
mandate and that seems like a threat to
democracy or maybe it's people in the
federal government proclaiming that they
could stack the supreme court
or that they could simply override the
filibuster and do whatever they want on
the pure majoritarian basis
right that's kind of a threat to to
democratic rights but that's not what
joe biden is talking about according to
the democrats the threat to democracy is
the existence of republicans
the republicans themselves are a threat
to democracy and then they always point
to january 6th as though january 6 was
ever going to turn into a full-blown
coup i'm sorry it wasn't and if you
believe it was you're an idiot i don't
know what to tell you
january 6 was not a full-blown coup it
was ugly it was despicable you shouldn't
be storming the capitol building in the
hopes of harming the vice president of
the united states or of delaying the
business of constitutional government
you were involved in a riot you should
go to jail also if you believe that we
are really on the verge of democracy
ending in america on january 6th it's
because you are an idiot or you are
politically motivated or both
the people are literally being charged
right now for participating in january
6th who are posting on instagram
saying i don't always drink but when i'm
invading the capital and drinking i
drink coors light does that sound so
it's the light beer hall pooch as
someone put it online like does that
sound like a real coup but according to
the democrats it is because again the
entire thing here is that if they can't
justify their own failures they can at
least pretend that their opponents are
hitler according to politico joe biden
is now going to go in front of the world
and lament the state of american
democracy
on thursday biden is going to open the
summit for democracy says politico
reduced by the pandemic to a giant
two-day zoom conference leaders of 110
countries will make public commitments
to fortify their own in some cases
rather notional democracies biden seems
to have been mugged by reality
unlike his predecessors of whatever
persuasion this president has taken
office in a moment when a democratic
future in the united states can no
longer be taken for granted
really
really and if that's the case wouldn't
it be more because the government has
seized powers that are way beyond its
constitutional purview
is anyone really afraid that they're
never going to get to vote for president
again
is anybody truly afraid they're not
going to get to vote for their local rep
what are we talking about here
but this is the democratic pitch
no task seems more urgent than
protection of democracy at home and
abroad according to politico secretary
of state anthony blinken said quote in
every conversation i've heard joe biden
have with a foreign leader the
centerpiece of the conversation has been
that he sees the fundamental struggle of
our time as the face-off between
autocracy and democracy and it's
fundamental for the u.s to lead the
effort toward the democratic resilience
and reinvigoration around the world
biden hopes to reassert america's faith
in democracy after four years in which
former president donald trump toted to
dictators to lead the world's
democracies in the heart of struggle
with autocratic states above all china
for the hearts and minds of the world
citizens and to agree on strategies to
fortify democracy
fortify democracies against internal and
external threats
if this effort should fulfill even a
part of those hopes biden will be
remembered as the fdr like figure whom
he aspires to be
and first of all we should note here
that fdr was not the great
apex of of american democracy that dude
was engaged in some behaviors like for
example the complete imprisoning of all
japanese-american citizens uh
not fdr is a bad example of of the
nation's best democrats like small d
democrat but
the this is the this is the basic
outline that has now been created by the
left
is that we will be incredibly radical
and our radicalism is justified because
the other side is just so evil
so how is the right to meet this
well the right should be able to meet
this with good policy the right should
be able to meet this with good policy
and with good ideas and with tried and
true ideas
but it seems that many on the right have
bought into this rhetoric because their
brains were fried by trump
there's no question that trump was a
reaction to the left
that american politics just like all
politics is incredibly reactionary and
people tend to react very strongly to
things and then to sort of put aside
qualms in pursuit of the reaction
but there are some people on the right
whose brains are so fried that they
think that the future of democracy is
indeed
in the hands of democrats
and this is how you end up with an
entire wing of the
establishment republican
thinking
that that is dedicated to the
proposition that you should be a
democrat
this is why you will see the
conservative case for california or
you'll see the conservative case for
drag queen story hour or according to
david brooks essentially the
conservative case for voting democrat
we'll get to that in just one second
because it is delusional
first let's talk about the fact that you
should right now if you own a home
refinance it's just a thing you should
do you should do it before the rates
rise
mortgage rates are at historic lows
again that means you could easily drop
your rate and your monthly payment
that's not going to last forever the fed
is going to taper mortgage rates are
going to go up everybody knows that next
year mortgage rates are going to rise
all you have to do right now to talk
about refinancing is call american
financing america's home for home loans
take advantage of a free mortgage review
that's right free meaning no pressure no
obligation no upfront fees just a simple
conversation with a salary based
mortgage consultant someone who's going
to listen to and guide you so you're
getting a custom loan that achieves your
goals from lower rates to shorter terms
even the ability to access cash from
your equity they're ready to help you
find the best deal possible our
consultants can help you save up to a
thousand dollars a month you might even
skip to mortgage payments creating
greater upfront savings and you can
pre-qualify for free by calling
seven two 866
thirty three hundred that's eight six
six seven two one thirty three hundred
or visit americanfinancing.net nmls 182
nmlsconsumeraccess.org go check them out
right now
americanfinancing.net alrighty coming up
we'll get to david is much belly who
piece in the atlantic about how american
conservatism is dead
i'll get to that in a moment first as
the biden administration continues to
try to cram down their vaccine mandates
it's more important than ever that we
continue to fight it so far the pushback
is working not only has the osha mandate
received a nationwide stay this week the
federal court enjoined the biden
administration
from enforcing their federal contractor
vaccine mandate this is great news but
we would not be receiving that news
without the continued application of
pressure because the bite administration
is not backing down recently biden
announced his winter covered plan which
sounds less like pumpkin spice latte and
a lot more like mandates and more
mandates and then mandates to fly to
vaccinate in order to fly and all the
rest of this this would be a wrench and
travel plans for millions of americans
anthony fauci yesterday said that that
if you're having a holiday party you
should try to force all your family
members to backs and this is all crazy
only pressure only pressure is going to
make them stop this that's why we filed
a lawsuit against joe biden's vaccine
mandate for private employers the
government does not get to make our
private medical choices for us or
dictate how we live our lives based on
those choices we need your help if you
haven't signed our petition against joe
biden's vax mandate i need you to head
on over to dailywire.com do not comply
to add your name we need to send an
overwhelming message to this
administration the american people will
not comply our goal is to reach a
million signatures that would provide a
major boost to our legal challenge we
have nearly 750 000 signatures so far we
need your help to cross the finish line
please sign the petition at
dailywire.com do not comply share our
petition with all of your friends and
family let's send a message so loud the
biden administration cannot ignore us
also
it is now a matter of utmost importance
you go pick up a copy of matt walsh's
new children's book johnny the walrus
why well because his book not only sold
out within the first 24 hours it is now
the number one l-g-b-t-q-i-a-a-p-z
ampersand backslash colon hebrew bet
little tilde thing that goes over the n
in spanish plus best seller on amazon
and yes the book is sold out don't worry
you can reserve your copy at amazon to
get your hands on the next batch
shipping out soon johnny the walrus is
the exhilarating magical tale of a young
boy who pretends he's a walrus which is
a great adventure until the internet
tells johnny's mommy that johnny
actually is a walrus and she must as a
good mother upholds his trans walrus
identity if you know mance brain
you know the book's going to be twisted
and hysterical you should go buy it
right now head on over to amazon reserve
your copy of matt's timely masterpiece
johnny the walrus today you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so just as i have said that the
left is justifying its bad behavior by
pointing to the evils of the right there
are some people on the right who'll do
the same who will justify bad behavior
by pointing to the evils of the left my
view of conservatism has always been
that you don't get to be non-virtuous
just because the other side is being
non-virtuous now you do have to protect
yourself you have to stand up for
yourself and you have to be muscular in
doing all of those things but there is a
wing of the republican party the
establishment republican party the the
kind of thinking man over at the new
york times editorial page the david
brooks character who believes that the
best way to demonstrate your fealty to
decency is to simply kowtow to the left
because you're so embarrassed by the
right and these are people who just
never got over trump it's not a shock
coming from david brooks who once
praised i kid you not the pleat in
barack obama's pants that's the thing
that david brooks once did but this guy
was considered the in-house conservative
at the new york times now he has a piece
in the atlantic which is definitely
where you're going to want to write
about american conservatism the same
magazine that dumped kevin williamson
for the great sin of being pro-life
he has a piece there called what
happened to american conservatism the
rich philosophical tradition i fell in
love with has been reduced to fox news
and voter suppression says david brooks
he says i fell in love with conservatism
in my twenties as a politics and crime
reporter in chicago i often found myself
around public housing projects like
cabrini green and the robert taylor
homes which had been built with the best
of intentions but had become nightmares
the urban planners who designed those
projects thought they could improve
lives by replacing rams shackle old
neighborhoods with a series of neatly
ordered high-rises but as the
sociologist richard senate who lived in
parts of the cabrini green complex as a
child noted the planners never really
consulted the residents themselves by
the time i encountered the projects
there were national symbols of urban
decay
back then i thought of myself as a
socialist seeing the fallout from the
situation prompted a shocking
realization this is exactly what that
guy i read in college had predicted
human society is unalterably complex
edmund burke argued if you try to
re-engineer it based on this impressive
simplistic schema of your own reason you
will unintentionally cause significant
harm right this is one of the
fundamental bases of conservatism is the
idea that rationalism is not proof
positive that you should do a thing that
we are human beings are uniquely capable
of coming up with bad reasons to do
things and so wisdom of the past is a
really good guide to what has worked and
what has not right this is the argument
that edmund burke made in the face of
the sort of floating rights of the
french revolution his idea was that if
you try to re-engineer society ground up
you're going to fail because society is
really really complex and he shouldn't
screw with it too much
right this is the old gk chesterton
quote about the difference between a
wise conservative and a foolish liberal
a wise conservative comes across a fence
in an empty field doesn't know why it's
there and and says i'm not going to tear
that down until i know why that was
there in the first place a liberal comes
across the fence says i don't know why
that's there i'm tearing it out
and and so accepting the reality of
people making decisions in the past and
that you have a tradition that has been
handed down to you is really important
so conservatism is very much about
tradition now that tradition is also
tied into human reason and it's tied
into received rights
okay so david brooks talks about his
version of conservatism he says what
passes for conservatism now however is
nearly the opposite of the burkian
conservatism i encountered then
today what passes for the worldview of
the right is a set of resentful
animosities a partisan attachment to
donald trump or tucker carlson a sort of
mental brutalism the rich philosophical
perspective that dazzled me has been
reduced to fox news and voter
suppression
he says i recently went back and re-read
the yellowing conservatism books i've
lugged around with me over the decades i
wondered whether i'd be embarrassed or
ashamed of them i have to tell you i
wasn't embarrassed i was enthralled all
over again
and i came away thinking conservatism is
truer and more profound than ever and
that to be a conservative today you have
to oppose the republican party so here
we go the conservative case for the
democratic party which currently is
rejecting all wisdom of the past right
this is the the soft-headedness of some
of the republican establishment when i
say republican establishment i mean
people the the the lincoln project gang
and the david brooks's of the world and
the entire
literati of of the bulwark you know a
group of people who have basically
decided that they are going to side more
often than not with democrats because
democrats hold the keys to the future
because they're just so angry at
republicans for going overboard on on
donald trump
okay that's
that's wild it's a it's a wild
perspective because if you're trying to
decide which party is more likely to
mirror your priorities of preserving the
wisdom of the past and not following
rationalistic desires to destroy
everything that we know to be true
already
in the pursuit of some sort of aimless
utopia
then i don't know how in the world you
could side with the democrats this is a
party that currently denies the reality
of biological sex
this is a party that suggests that
racial essentialism is a functional
feature of american life
this is a party that believes that
centralized power through government is
the solution to your problems and and
people like david brooks are saying that
future lies with the democratic party
for conservatives
it's nuts
says says david brooks this essay is a
reclamation project it's an attempt to
remember how modern conservatism started
what core wisdom it contains and why
that wisdom is still needed today
he points out the history of
conservatism which springs from the the
the enlightenment and from the peace of
westphalia and the end of the religious
wars in europe
he says
one camp which we associate with the
french enlightenment put its faith in
reason some thought a decent social
order can be built when primitive
passions like religious zeal are
marginalized and tamed when individuals
are educated to use their highest
faculty reason to pursue enlightened
self-interest and when government
organizes society using the tools of
science another camp which we associate
with the scottish or british
enlightenment of david hume and adam
smith did not believe human reason is
powerful enough to control human
selfishness most of the time our reason
merely rationalizes our selfishness they
do not believe that individual reason is
powerful enough to even comprehend the
world around us let alone enable leaders
to engineer society from the top down
this is one of core conservatives
principles epistemological modesty or
humility or humility in the face of what
we don't know about a complex world and
a conviction that social change should
be steady but cautious and incremental
down the centuries conservatives have
always stood against the arrogance of
those who believe they have the ability
to plan history
okay so i have a question
how in the world are you saying that you
need to side with the democrats david
brooks
how
explain
like truly explain
he says conservatism certainly has an
acute awareness of sin selfishness greed
lust conservatives also believe that in
the right circumstances people are
motivated by the positive moral emotions
like sympathy and benevolence these
moral sentiments move you to be outraged
by cruelty to care for your neighbor to
feel proper affection for your imperfect
country they motivate you to do the
right thing
your emotions can be trusted
conservatives believe when they are
cultivated rightly
the key phrase of course is cultivated
rightly
the only way to govern an unformed
creature would be through a prison state
if a person has not been trained by a
community
right so you need a community
so there's no state of nature you grow
up in a community all of this is correct
this is a correct assessment of of what
conservatism has typically represented
now conservatism does have a place for
liberty conservatism is not just about
accepting the wisdom of the past it is
about bringing up people in accordance
with right reason which is a natural law
term the idea being that you have to
look at the universe discern its rules
and then try to abide by those rules
that is the that is that way lies human
happiness natural right and natural law
are related natural law which is the
idea that human beings have the capacity
to understand much of the universe and
then they can derive fundamental
propositions for life from the nature of
that universe
that has an outgrowth in natural rights
which is the idea that along with those
laws comes fears of liberty
okay so conservatism is about all of
that because that is part of the
received wisdom of the past
okay but somehow david brooks then comes
to the conclusion that the future lies
with democrats who hate you and hate
conservatism and hate the wisdom of the
past and wished and wish to level all of
it
so david brooks continues
he says i really i realize that every
worldview has the vices of its virtues
conservatives are supposed to be
epistemologically modest but in real
life this modesty can turn into british
anti-intellectualism a contempt for
learning and expertise conservatives are
supposed to prize local community but
this orientation can turn into narrow
parochialism can produce xenophobic and
racist animosity toward immigrants a
tribal hostility toward outsiders a
paranoid response when confronted with
even a hint of diversity and pluralism
conservatives are supposed to cherish
moral formation but this can turn into
rigid and self-righteous moralism and
conservatives are supposed to revere the
past but this can turn into an abject
deference to whoever holds power
and he thinks this is what's happened to
american conservatism
he says that that american conservatism
is uh is is now hardening into
xenophobia and brutalism
he says that that
he thinks that the tension between
america and conservatism is too great
he thinks that that donald trump is the
opposite of berkey and conservatism he
thinks that the future of conservatism
lies again in moving away from these
traditional american values
and even from just in order to distance
himself from trump he's basically
willing to go side with alexander
ocasio-cortez it seems to be the main
pitch here
he says that conservatism makes sense
only when it's trying to preserve social
conditions that are basically healthy
america's racial arrangements are
fundamentally unjust and now he's
speaking the language to the left
america's race relations were
fundamentally unjust in 1965 they're not
fundamentally unjust in 2021 they're not
okay but he has embraced this because it
makes him feel good about himself and he
gets to hang out with his liberal
friends
he says that that conservatives have
fallen down the rabbit hole of believing
too much in free markets
which of course is incredibly silly if
you've seen the republican party these
days
but
again the reason that i point out this
essay is to point out
that there's an entire wing just
democrats understand
that the only way to justify their own
agenda is to see republicans as enemies
and there are a bunch of people on the
right who are so self-doubting and so
self-loathing because so many of their
friends did something they don't like in
backing donald trump that they're
willing to go along with it
it's it's an it's an amazing
transformation and it's it's an amazing
and debilitating
move
right david brooks says that he is
content to plant himself in the
rightward edge of the leftward tendency
in the more promising soil of the
moderate wing of the democratic party if
its progressive wing sometimes seems to
have learned nothing from the failures
of government and to remote cultural
stances that divide america at least the
party as a whole knows what year it is
in 1980 the core problem of the age was
statism in 2021 the core threat is
social decay
and he thinks that social decay is going
to be arrested by the democratic party
the democratic party is the party of
social decay that's the party of
california
if conservatives can't see that then
fine go side with the democrats
really we have no use for you if you
cannot see that the party of social
decay is the party that wants taxpayer
funded
abortion magnets
then i do not know what to tell you at
this point alrighty we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content coming up soon as the matte wall
show it airs 1 30 pm eastern be sure to
check it out over at daily wire i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica crans the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show